l' architecture est l'une des plus
anciennes profession du monde tout au
long de l'évolution
notre corps est resté en partie inadapté
au climat nous avons besoin pour nous
protéger de vêtements bien sûr mais
aussi d'abris de toi et de murs tous
adaptés au climat que nous habitons
c'est pourquoi lé architecture a
toujours été adaptée aux ressources et
au climat par ressources nous entendons
ce dont nous avons besoin pour nous
installer quelque part il s'agit
principalement de l'eau de la nourriture
de matériaux ou encore d'énergie par
climat nous entendons les facteurs
environnementaux particuliers qui
caractérise un site
mais au cours des dernières décennies
l'accès illimité mondialisée aux
ressources et l'énergie nous a conduit à
une situation où l'architecturé le
secteur du bâtiment sont devenus
responsables de 40 % des émissions
mondiales de carbone en moyenne en
europe 30% des émissions de co2 ont lieu
avant même la mise en service du
bâtiment et selon des recherches
récentes avec les nouvelles
réglementations sur les économies
d'énergie les bâtiments sont nos yeux
plus performants et cette proportion est
passée à 60%
cela signifie donc qu'au moment même où
vous recevez les clés de votre nouveau
bâtiment
celui ci a déjà est lui plus de co2 dans
l'atmosphère qu'il en émettra pendant le
reste de sa vie pour atteindre les
objectif de neutralité carbone fixé par
le giec
il faut donc transformer radicalement le
mode de fonctionnement du secteur de la
construction en tant qu architecte
il est maintenant de notre devoir de
transformer notre pratique et de
développer des projets architecturaux
radicaux qui intègre des méthodes de
construction décarbonés et des
stratégies énergétiques passive
après avoir passé près de dix ans à être
il est architecturé apprendre à
concevoir et à construire dans des
contextes urbains globalisé nous sommes
sortis de l'école complètement incapable
de répondre à ces questions
après le diplôme il ya un peu plus de
dix ans mon partenaire et moi même avons
voyagé pour visiter les territoires de
forte croissance urbaine
souvent construits sans planification
sans architecte et hors des villes et
avec souvent un rapport à l'énergie un
peu faussée nous sommes également rendus
dans les endroits reculés caractérisée
par l'absence de ressources et les
climats extrêmes
nous voulions comprendre les dépendances
et les relations de architecture avec
les sources de matériaux et d'énergie à
disposition en afrique du nord par
exemple nous avons étudié et
développement urbain en cours hors des
agglomérations
incapable d'exister dans une ère post
carbone complètement dépendant aux
énergies fossiles alors même que
l'archer cure traditionnelle dans ces
régions étaient justement le résultat de
stratégies climatiques passive amélioré
au fil des siècles
en egypte les maisons traditionnelles du
caire sont par exemple dotées de
capteurs devant appelé mal caf qui capte
les vents dominants venant du nord et
d'une cheminée centrale a pris 12 carats
qui permet à l'air chaud de s'échapper
en été ce type de maison est simplement
un climatiseur naturel et nous pensons
que nous pouvons combiner ses
connaissances régionales traditionnelle
avec les capacités scientifiques
d'aujourd'hui une meilleure
compréhension précise des conditions du
site et des matériaux disponibles est
désormais essentiel pour développer des
conceptions architecturales intégré et
ne plus dépendre des ressources fossiles
mais nous pensons également que nous
devons utiliser la technologie pour être
plus radicaux et plus efficace dans
cette entreprise
les architectes doivent travailler
activement avec des outils des
instruments des cartes emprunté aux
climatologues aux spécialistes des
sciences de la terre voire même aux
biologistes
ils doivent comprendre les phénomènes
invisible et les facteurs de sites de
manière multi échelles et
transdisciplinaire et ce n'est qu'en
intégrant le calcul et les bases de
données que nous pourrons parvenir à une
réduction drastique des émissions de
carbone et des besoins en énergie au
cours du siècle passé
les principaux matériaux utilisés par
les architectes ont été le béton l'acier
et le verre
aujourd'hui les nouveaux matériels
architecture doivent de 20
ir l'air l'eau la température et
l'humidité et nous devons apprendre à
manipuler les radiations solaires
les flux d'air l'humilité et la lumière
du jour avec toute la créativité dont
les architectes ont su faire preuve au
cours des siècles passés décarbonés
architecture signifie passer de
bâtiments générique qui dépendent de
chaîne d'approvisionnement globalisé à d
architecture spécifique ancrée dans des
géographies propres les projets doivent
être conçus avec des matériaux g aux
sources et comme la terre et bio sourcés
comme le bois disponibles localement et
leur climat doit être contrôlée
passivement il est temps de remettre au
premier plan ces conditions d'existence
larcher cure et de se débarrasser de
l'idée beau dern de la forme parfaite
nous ne pouvons plus attendre de trachée
cure doit désormais impérativement être
neutre en carbone flexible adaptable et
intégré au climat et l'environnement
merci votre attention